The FHIR data model is instantiated in a set of what will
probably be some 150 or more modular resources.
The current release 3 version of the standard organizes
its 117 resources and related documentation in the five levels you see here.
Level 1 is the standard's basic framework and consists of 30 resources.
Level 2 supports implementation and binding to
external specifications and contains 26 resources.
Level 3 provides structural and process elements of
real world healthcare systems and provides 37 resources.
Level 4 is for record keeping and data exchange and contains 13 resources.
Level 5 provides the ability to reason about
healthcare processes and contains 11 resources.
It is likely that the number of resources will increase,
and existing ones may change over time.
So, I provide a link to the resource index page on the FHIR site.
It summarizes the resources and their subdivisions in several useful ways.
Note the number after each resource indicates its maturity on a scale of zero to five.
These numbers will also increase over time as standards definition proceeds.
At present, the lower levels are generally more mature.
We cannot cover FHIR comprehensively in this survey course,
so I can't overemphasize the importance of studying the excellent,
well-organized FHIR website to gain a fuller understanding of the standard.
To get you started on that,
here are a few particularly interesting resources.
The definition of a resource is itself contained in the resource resource,
in the foundational framework part of the foundational level.
Earlier, I said that valuesets can be represented in a resource.
It is the valueset resource in the terminology division of the foundational level.
Later, we will discuss FHIR profiles.
The structured definition resource in
the conformance division of the second implementation level represents profiles.
The group resource in the third level specifies a particular set of patients,
providers, medications, and so on,
for purposes such as reporting or tracking.
The subscription resource in
the other division at the foundational level is used to create
a push of FHIR resources that match criteria specified in the resource.
Finally, level 5 includes support for clinical reasoning.
Earlier, we discussed clinical decision support,
and I pointed to tight EHR integration as a benefit of
FHIR to obtain provider adoption of these tools.
The new CDS Hooks specification,
developed by the same Harvard group that created SMART on FHIR,
supports the integration of clinical logic,
similar to what we saw with the Arden Syntax into EHRs in order to,
among other things, launch FHIR apps when
a patient's clinical situation suggests they might be of value.
A goal of FHIR release 4 is to unify
the CDS Hooks specification with the clinical reasoning module.
This should be another important step toward broader use of clinical decision support.
When I last asked Graham,
he estimated that the first normative version of the standard might appear in 2018.
Until then, FHIR is a Standard for Trial Use, STU.
You may see the term Draft Standard for Trial Use, or DSTU,
but STU is now HL7s preferred designation.